[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
hitches me and my pack if i see 12 i'm
doing that dash unclip bass better watch
how you chat
break down the box we're doing some mess
up yeah i just need elastic bands sweet
little one won't come to the gap
demon time to the arch that back she got
no sense but her brain is mad
violent human ultra attack the [ __ ] to
watch but it's also kept
how many racks have you wrapped in bands
free kazzy my slime my [ __ ]
you know he's loose he's also attacked
i'm writing none of that man are you mad
my things ain't running it back stepping
through that's me on my back
hold on wait hold on wait don't know who
it is i ain't hiding my face
demon [ __ ] with a pulled up tongue the
sloppy's mad you know it's so crazy
my man heard one all in his face tell
your man don't come my way
so i'll turn up man give her some break
step in the right way ain't doing
anything
two two step bro got in case flinging s
we
remember that day remember that day bro
assisting me with his blades not for
that mate let's talk about papes
i'm addicted to this cake growing up and
whipping up grub i'm backing up blood
the day's going great
hold on wait they can't chat with my
names on workers and they get minimum
wage get too close you might see my
plate
so much juice all over the pavement
lucky dash you would have got shave
that's enough i say no names
that's enough i say no names
that's enough i say no names
[Music]
[Music]
monster on your phone like dead heart
coming popping i got powers right by the
station
i run it the name's called austin but
i'd be one choking his magic stick oh
[ __ ] a door just locking up where
they're babies coming like johnson's
irrelevant [ __ ]
silly imposters you don't want to get
one touched by emma's long you'll get
cracked like lobsters rampy [ __ ]
you know young bosses hold on wait you
know they can't stop this the floor's
all crazy it's hard to unlock this fling
it in ten that's a hold of the profit
when this [ __ ] come flat like pizza
[ __ ] it though that's a hole on the
topping the dot dot come way too long
handy mo gotta with a pretty low face
slim ways come in just block this then
you pull up in a 125 or a 2.0 man you
know we've got options it's intense roll
city's onions badness blasted left them
unconscious when i know why they hate me
it's obvious can't do my own thing and
got bosses i just laugh
they've been doing this [ __ ] for years
and i see no profit i just graph
and i'd rather just get them first i'm
just being that honest with a pre-law
thing off the ground
bex is mad and she's giving me knowledge
i could never just leave my dog me and
my brother that's worse than grumman
[Music]
you